Oh my gosh, doki, doki, action game!
I'm so excited!
It's Minky.
That's me!
Hi, Minto!
Hello!
Good luck, Minto!
Thank you!
Hello!
Hi, hi, hi!
Wiggle, wiggle, wiggle.
The song is a jam, though.
Maybe by the end of this though, I will hate it.
Interesting to see how we incorporate cannibalism into this
game.
If I lose, I will eat my foot.
Is it cannibalism if you eat yourself?
Self-cannibalism.
I agreed to let Minto haunt me forever.
Thank you, thank you.
Hello, Minto, and I booze like you.
Okay, real talk.
Have you ever actually read the terms and conditions once?
Can't say I ever have, but mad respect to anyone who did.
I...
Auto-cannibalism is a thing, yes.
Oh, baby, oh, baby.
I did once.
I was really bored.
I think, okay, it depends, though.
the terms of terms of service for you know because like I
can't believe it's been 13 months already thank you about
snacks thank you like a gym membership okay I tried once for
Apple I gave up that's yeah see like some of them are like
not as long but some of them are gonna be like insanely long
no but you know I give major respect to anybody that does
read them and then reports about when there's something
strange in there.
You know what I mean?
Somebody has to do it.
Can we all agree that Minto is pretty neat?
Agree, agree, agree.
It's somebody's job to read through like the terms of
services that get put out and be like, hey, this doesn't
look so right, I think.
Oh yeah, I'm a full-grown Now big love!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
A whole year.
Soon we'll be having people to two years.
And they will be rainbow.
It's so exciting.
Agree!
Thank you, pregnant!
Talk to her lawyer.
Talk to my lawyer.
How many...
I wonder how many of terms of services are being written by
like chat GPT nowadays though.
But they have to be checked over by like a lawyer usually,
no?
Would have chat GPT put something in funny in there.
If you agree, you always have to do a silly dance on the
first Monday of every month at 2 p.m.
Oh, Tuesday, Victor, welcome back!
Hi, Victor.
I'm so glad I finally get to watch live again.
My new work schedule makes it impossible, usually.
Charitable!
Oh, my gosh!
Welcome back.
Thank you.
Oh, hi, Vince.
Oh, Steiner?
Just checking.
You did read the terms of agreement on our contract, right?
I read our contract.
Why are you super chatting me?
Stop that.
What the heck?
What are you doing?
Get out of here.
Did Steiner read it though?
Actually, I snuck that clause in.
I snuck that clause in before signing it.
I wrote, Steiner must dance on the first Monday of...
Steiner Monday must dance on the first Monday of the month
at 2 p.m.
Which 2 p.m.
is it?
All of them.
Hourly, you must dance at 2 p.m.
It's 2 p.m.
somewhere.
Dance.
Dance, manager, dance.
All of them.
You guys, when I first came up with my schedule, I didn't
realize that there was going to be a million things.
happening this saturday so today there's a lot of things
that i want to watch so i fear that today might be a shorter
stream but that's okay lots of things going on is exciting
though when april fools a company added to the customer
agreed to give their soul to them i think 70 something did
their company graciously relinquished their claim later oh
that's so nice yeah lots of stuff happening around Superb
Owl is tomorrow!
I know!
I will be playing out in Wake.
Yeah, Doki's stream...
She's in an hour, right?
Hold on, I'm double checking.
Oh, I guess more like 45 minutes now.
I would like to raid her.
Because she's doing like a celebration for her second
anniversary?
Yeah, in 45 minutes.
None of us read the terms and conditions, but we should.
Some companies have hidden cash prizes in their terms and
condition.
Cash, money, prize!
Yeah, I agree to allow Mint Phantom to possess me.
Thank you.
Actually, by subscribing, you already allow that.
No, I'm just kidding.
By viewing my profile, you allow me to possess your body.
You allow me to possess your body.
mean how cash money of them so let's get into it oh you can
play the game after agreeing to all the terms of service oh
there's only 12 of them this is so easy user attitudes oh
there's also a timer users must devote themselves
wholeheartedly to the game and actively and passionately
enjoy it if a user forgets the original purpose of enjoying
the game they will automatically lose the game i'm having
fun i'm having fun if a user loses sight of how to enjoy the
game you guys just lost the game
in the pursuit of competition or results this will be
considered a deviation from the purpose of the game we
strongly recommend that users who find themselves
users who find themselves in such a situation take a break
from the game even if only of mine.
Like, I agree.
Oh, I got an achievement for that, for agreeing.
Oh, for mint!
Damn it!
Why are they shaking?
Are they scared?
Wait.
Warm comments from users such as, it was fun or it was
interesting, will bring warmth, like spring sunshine to the
hearts of developers who are facing unknown bugs and never
approaching deadlines and will help increase their
motivation to continue development.
Understand that developers are human too And will overlook
minor glitches and typos We'll sincerely admire the efforts
Aww, we love the devs Oh Oh, it disappeared Oh, oh, I got it
I mean, today is also the anniversary of the jazz karaoke
There was a before and after that stream Is it really?
Oh my gosh, I should do like another jazz karaoke karaoke
stream now, shouldn't I?
Of like, in a week or something.
Oh my gosh, Cat Captain!
Thank you so much for the Akai Super!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Yeah.
Oh, recognize how difficult it is to completely eliminate
bugs during the game.
Discover that bug in the game shall consider it to be a
hidden feature.
Ooh, oh.
Agree?
Okay.
What if you're colorblind?
line what is your colorblind though what is this well
sharing oh i don't need to read these do i shoot oh oh oh oh
oh i see i see we don't hit that one oh oh oh easy i've
played i've played yeah I've done Pachinko before.
Easy.
The Plinkado Board.
Addiction.
What does that say?
Oh, wait.
Both of you say disagree.
Wait a second.
But they both say disagree.
Is there a degree somewhere?
Devote to loving the game.
What about the...
Agree.
Somewhere.
Is it in here?
I strongly recommend finding out of the way to regain the
peace of mind.
Just to read the TOS carefully.
I am checky!
I am!
Oh!
Oh my god.
I thought it was going to be like behind it or something.
Agreed!
If you were colorblind it wouldn't... Oh yeah, you still
just click...
You still just click...
Agreed now, don't you?
Handling of personal information.
Oh, what is this?
Oh.
Whoop.
Oh, gosh, oh, gosh, oh, gosh, oh, gosh.
Okay.
Whoop.
Oh, my gosh.
It's like, it's like, uh, whoop.
It's like, uh, when they...
Oh, my God, oh, my God.
Oh my god.
Agreed.
When you have to take off a...
A...
A nugget.
A tablecloth.
You know?
And you have to...
Like really fast.
And without letting all the...
Have you guys ever done that before?
I've never...
I want to try it in like a rage room.
I want to set up like a table with a bunch of glass.
Like a bunch of china and stuff.
Find china.
And set it all up.
really nicely on the table and then
who is SS FV?
Oh my god, cat captain!
Thank you so much for the ping!
Thank you!
Sorry, I missed it, I think.
I tried it.
It didn't go well.
I think I could do it.
But that's why I would have to be in a rage room.
Have you guys ever done a rage room before?
Will I need one after this?
Do it with plastic to practice?
But the plastic wouldn't be like the heaviness that it needs
to be, right?
I would love to try.
I've heard places that you get to put on your own song.
You know?
You get to put on like your own like raging song.
And I think break stuff is too...
Is too like obvious.
You know what I mean?
I feel like the winner takes it all.
like the winner takes it all and you're like and like really
cathartic or the um the frank sinatra song oh what is a man
you know like i can imagine just like really releasing all
the emotions in that but i think break stuff also works very
well too really depends on what kind of emotion you're going
for sometimes they don't like you throw things what what's
the point
I see the vision.
Totally good for slow-mo, though.
You could slow-mo.
Yeah, Bohemian Rhapsody.
Yeah, yeah, that's another good one.
That's another good one.
Taking a sledgehammer to some tables while MyWay is playing.
That's what I'm saying!
You see the vision, right?
You're feeling it?
Snake Eater!
Snake Eater would also be a really...
A rage room!
With Snake Eater playing!
I give my life Not for honor But for you Crash, crash, crash
Rolls of nature Oh, it's you can I feel like with a rage
room you either go for like the For obviously like the Pure
rage like with a metal song or something Or you go for like
the cathartic like Like Emotional like Ah I need to get out
my feelings.
Dramatic or angry.
That's a good way.
Don't Stop Me Now works really well, too.
I could say it.
Don't Stop Me Now.
Now I want to sing.
Oh, my bad.
Handling of game data.
What is this?
Ha!
Oh.
Agree?
Ha!
What is it?
What is happening?
Oh.
what oh oh what is going why is it oh oh i'm playing flappy
bird oh my gosh
oh no oh shoot ah it's like a reverse flappy bird i was like
trying with my keyboard at first it's flappy bird where you
hit the obstacles instead of reverse trying to avoid them.
Farts out when you miss one.
Regarding fraud.
Cheating in this game is prohibited.
If you cheat, agree.
No!
He is tough from the beginning!
Oh no!
Oh, it's different too.
Oh my god.
fast oh my god it's i got
it i should have known that it would switch what the hell is
this oh are you here are you here
i have to search for it maybe oh oh oh oh oh it's in here
she's in here the one piece Oh my god Matroska Agree box
Can I just move these out of the way?
Cage Go over here Didis I think I need to get this one.
Catch.
Nice.
Release.
Wait.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Easy.
Catch.
Oh.
The one that I need to get.
Oh, it's not a release.
Catch.
Ah, ah, please catch.
Release.
Release!
Catch!
Ah!
Release!
Addiction.
I have
to be careful not to press.
I have to be careful not to press disagree on action.
Where's your motivation?
We're good?
That was easy?
No worries.
No problem.
Chance to win a luxurious prizes.
You get the prize, your dart hits.
Oh, wait.
This is like...
This feels like...
Oh my gosh.
This feels like luck almost.
Oh my god.
It goes so fast.
Ha!
Okay.
I got a scrubbing brush!
That's not what I- oh, only two chances.
It's the run killer.
There's no way left to agree.
And?
What about it?
This is fine.
I am not a robot.
What is the most important thing to you?
If I were Mr. Crabs, I'd say money.
But I'll say love.
I would say love.
Oh, oh, it's this one again, right?
Oh, no, it's different this time.
Oh my god.
There she is.
Agree.
How's the music and stuff, by the way?
What is this now?
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, uh, open.
Oh, shoot.
Wait, I need you.
Oh.
Uh.
Oh, no.
I need a G.
You have to spell it.
Arig!
Okay.
Wait, that makes it a little more difficult now, doesn't it?
Alright, hold on.
Uh, A.
G.
Oh, no, I could have used that R.
Oh, shoot.
Okay.
We still have time.
A gate?
What'd you call me?
Oh, shoot.
I forgot that there's a timer.
A, G, R, R.
Oh no, I couldn't use that E.
Ah, yes, good, good, good.
E.
Yeah!
Why are you again?
Oh, it's this one again.
Hoi!
Agree.
Thank-y-o!
Oh, yes!
Yes!
No!
Agree.
I can't just ask that in 2026.
Is this the one?
Disagree, disagree.
Oh!
There.
You give one shot?
That's so mean!
Scummy rage rooms charge per item slash hit.
Wait, no they don't.
What?
Better to pay a junkyard owner or buy stuff from Goodwill,
Amazon, and Kira.
Wait, they pay?
Or step on home?
No.
Does Minto make you go doki-doki?
Agree or agree?
Guys, a streamer even trying.
Oh, it's this one again.
Okay, okay.
Oh, here we go.
Oh.
Hint?
No.
What do you mean, hint?
I don't trust the game.
For the hint.
You know?
I don't really trust it.
Disagree.
How big is this map?
No, no cheaters.
Oh, I almost clicked it.
Disagree.
Oh.
What?
Does one say agree?
But it's red?
Click hint.
Is below here.
Oh, okay.
That's like so...
Hint!
Left of here.
You saw it!
Did you?
Up?
Oh!
Oh gosh, I'm ready.
Where are you?
Oh, never mind.
Never mind.
I thought it was the one that was going to fly at me.
Oh, wait.
Was there one in there?
Oh, ah, I see it.
I see it.
Agree.
I saw it.
Oh, okay.
That one wasn't so bad.
I haven't made it past...
Wait, no.
I think I've made it to six.
Oh,
shoot.
Oh, okay.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, sure.
Nice!
Kobe.
Ow!
Sorry, Kobe.
Kobe.
Yes, yes!
Oh, yeah!
That was so clean.
Oh,
I almost pressed the disagree.
Maybe I got to 7 instead.
Because I didn't get another achievement.
Oh, no.
I was right above it!
No!
Is this the one where it jumps up?
I'm clicking around.
Uh, which one was this again?
You need faster reflexes.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Why don't you stream then if you have faster reflexes than
me, huh?
Yeah?
I'm afraid...
Oh!
Ah-ha!
What's this one?
Oh!
Oh, I see it.
Oh, oops.
Is it the same one?
It's not the same one.
Oh, oh, here it is.
Agree.
Alright, I'm starting to learn.
Did you see that first though?
I clicked it and it didn't register.
want you all to see.
You all saw that, right?
I clicked it.
It showed the clicking animation and it did not register.
It did not register.
You saw that.
The game is sabotaging me.
It's cheating.
Click stronger.
I'll testify in court.
Clicked it.
Oh, I clicked it.
What is this one now?
Confirm?
If your mouse is hard to see.
No, it's me.
I'm not going to change it.
That was mean.
Oh, is this the one where it jumps up in the air?
No!
It's flare.
It's like an anomaly game.
Oh, there you are.
Where's Wilde?
There's so many.
Confirmed.
Agreed to all check boxes.
There's more?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh my gosh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no Wait, no, no, no, no, God, no, please, it's gonna
zoom.
That's the run killer!
You were saying.
Agreed?
Oh, it's this one again, okay.
Why does it feel like there's way more this time than
before, huh?
I'm reading them just in case they don't just in case this
one of them says disagree you know
I know you're fast enough to catch a veto it's that darn
slide whistle it is never get tired of the sound effect of
the green button fly.
It's like it's mocking me.
Okay.
It's fine.
We were still in early game.
I would have never gotten it, you guys.
Great reading, Bito.
I would have never gotten that.
That one would definitely kill me.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
You know what?
Maybe hints are not cheats.
Disagree.
Mm-mm.
It's only a 3x3.
You don't understand.
Have you reviewed?
Yes.
Did you really?
They're really long.
Did you really read them in?
Yes.
Seems to me no truth.
Don't lie.
I...
It's not even that long!
Yes.
Were there any parts of the terms you could not agree with?
No.
You understand that you fully agree.
Yes.
Really?
Seriously?
Did you really?
Yes.
So this counts as your agreement?
Agree!
More like Higged, fried tom.
Psychin' me out!
Psychin' me out.
Oh.
uh hello where are you oh oh i see it
sorry for being late never apologize surprise we are still
at the terms and terms and conditions glad i made it in time
before the game started yeah yeah yeah we just got a few
things left to agree to and we'll be Pimmed ass
Addition Subtraction 24 Minus 41 No
Just left to right I thought it was addition and subtraction
You know what It's fine.
I didn't go to...
to basic math class.
That might be news to some people.
I didn't go to... I don't know math.
I didn't go to basic math class.
24 minus 3.
21.
Uh... 30.
Uh...
59?
...
You're thinking of multiplication for order of operations.
When do you use the PEMDAS when you do it, though?
I thought it was always.
You ever look at a word so long it stops looking like
something a human would say?
What is an agree?
Why did we make this a word?
It just sounds right, no?
Agree.
It's when there's brackets.
Oh!
Oh, okay, okay.
Thank you, everybody.
Antoa, thank you so much for the 10kettos.
Always, but wait.
Plus and minus are treated in the same order.
Meep, thank you so much for the 10kettos.
Thank you.
Wait.
So, so if it's just like that, then if there's
multiplication and division, would put those before but if
there's but if there's just addition subtraction it's
counted the same this is math class now envision the agree
button is a special edition r18 dogen of oselot and snake
there's a limited supply of them and you can only get one
chance to buy and now go click that agree button next time
we try them we thank you for this every time yes okay do you
agree that Yeah, there's even song about it, I heard.
P-E, parentheses, M-D, parentheses, A-S.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Duck boy, welcome to Mamboship, thank you!
Subtraction is just adding a negative number.
They're the same thing.
Sure.
Do anything in parentheses first.
Oh, then handle exponents.
that as a little like two a tiny two right
Andrew welcome to Mambusha thank you yes okay the parrot
number on your shoulder oh what am i a pirate oh
the agreed text is missing and you cannot agree because the
button is unclear Please find the agree text.
Oh.
There's so many.
Oh my goodness.
Agi.
Um.
Oh, geez.
Is it, can it be diagonal or?
uh, uh, uh, yeah.
Uh, top row.
You see it?
Oh, here it is.
You're right.
A.
Elf.
Good job.
guys wow sure that was a perfect math class i heard it's
going to yeah it's perfect it's perfect me a gaga
oh no i think this is the run killer no way there's no way
anybody could follow that
i lost it at the second day i think it's this one i was so
close
That one's truly evil.
That one's just...
What is this?
Oh, push.
Push.
This is what my mama says.
Easy.
My mama says push push.
Push.
Agree.
Oh, check all the box.
Oh, this one again.
Oh.
Confirmed.
I really checked.
Did you read?
Read, read, read, read, read.
You check that box.
No, I read it carefully and thoughtfully.
Agree.
I'll be careful.
Careful, careful, careful.
I am closing with intent.
I am not just...
pressing the button I am making sure it doesn't say disagree
I am pushing with intent I will make
scary scary no what is this one
I like how some of them are like very similar but it's just
a little bit different you know
what a thrill with darkness and silence through the
night what a is this how this works or does it is it does it
is it this thing where like it you need to move along the
bars oh my gosh stop it okay i have to move along the bars
okay it takes every turn okay cool cool cool oh my no i lost
it okay
One, two, three, four, five,
six.
One, two, three.
Wait, I missed one.
What do you mean I missed a turn?
Oh, I have to start over?
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, I'm not gonna make it.
I just have to pick one.
You!
Oh.
Am I making it?
Never punished.
Oh, Tensai, Tensai, Tensai.
I was
so locked in.
Mint Tensai!
We made it to eight!
Oh,
how do I do this?
Oh, okay.
Oh,
oh, oh.
No,
no, no, evil.
Oh, oh.
Oh,
they're not solid until you let go.
I know, but it's difficult.
It's just difficult enough getting them to the green.
And then you have the bombs.
Sorry.
I wasn't paying attention.
I saw green.
Much like you guys, you see green women and you're like,
hunka-punga, greena-woman, hunka-punga.
Oh, yeah.
I saw green and I was like, yeah.
Yeah.
Oh.
That's fine.
Agreed.
Whoa!
That one is the worst one?
You think so?
I am closing with intent!
I will make Sure, I do not press disagree.
Yeah, I am closing and making sure there is no red behind
the next door.
Ha, he, he, he, he, he, he, oh my gosh, they even put it on
the other side.
You don't gotta call me out like that green woman.
What?
Where is your motivation?
Oh, it's this one again.
Come on.
Each time, no.
Each time I've gotten the agree on the second try.
Have you guys?
Every single time I've gotten a disagree on the first one
and an agree on the second one.
It's kind of crazy.
That was close though.
That was close.
Oh, great.
Oh, it's this one again.
Oh, yes.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, yeah, oh,
no, no, oh, yes, oh, oh, yes, oh, yes, yes, oh, yes, oh, no,
yes, yes, oh, yes, oh, yes, oh, yes, oh, yes, oh, yes, oh,
yes, oh, yes, oh, yes, oh, yes, oh, yes, oh, yes, oh, yes,
oh, yes, oh, yes, oh, yes, oh, yes, oh, yes, oh, oh, yes,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh
Yes, yes!
Oh,
it's this one again.
Wait,
how am I supposed to click it?
It won't... Oh, I had to go in a row, I think.
Okay.
Oh, I did it, I did it!
Oh!
Oh, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho!
What am I, shanto?
Impressive!
Really?
Well handled, thank you.
Thank you.
Clap.
Clap right now.
Please clap.
Clap for...
Impressive, snake.
Pachi, pachi.
Oh, thank you!
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
Oh, no.
Oh, yes!
That one wasn't so bad!
Yippee!
I was so ready to lose it.
Like in mind and in the game.
Yeah.
Oh, it's this one again.
Agree, agree, agree.
Oh, shoot.
No, I made that one.
Don't lie to me.
Tiny, tiny, tiny.
Oh!
I hear someone was begging for one.
of these oh yes thank you thank you for the clap thank you
thank you guys we made it to we made it to nine yippee
yippee what the heck is this he huh shoot
Okay, okay.
Oh, my God.
Agree.
Defiant heart.
Use turn.
I am level one.
Um.
Item.
Naughty book.
Read the naughty book.
Use body stiffened up.
Ouch.
My turn Magic Bee Bee Miho
Oh, okay Ouch My turn I feel like attacking Is not the right
thing to do Dark History Notebook I remembered something
embarrassing I learned a new spell I learned a new spell Oh,
he's sleeping!
Nothing happened!
What is happening?
Oh, look how much time we have!
What the hell?
Demon Black Zero.
Is this gonna hit?
Is this gonna kill me?
Oh, something happened?
I don't know what happened.
My's turn.
Okay.
Complained about many things.
My defense went down.
Welcome to Membushup!
Thank you!
What is his HP at though?
We don't know.
Blaze, blaze, burn.
I have no MP left.
Stamina tonic?
Ultimate sword!
14 damage.
Nice.
Six damage.
Scary.
Oh wait, can I...
Uh oh, wait, a medicinal herb?
Okay.
Good job, Minto, staying chill with this game!
I'm so chill!
What, did his...
Did his...
Color just change?
What's...
This, I think, textbook will probably bring us back MP, no?
Nothing happened.
Oh.
Dang it.
Okay.
Ouch!
5 damage.
Oh!
Gosh, we're taking a lot of damage!
Okay, HP, nice.
Stop attacking me!
Attack!
5 damage.
Complained!
Nice, nice, nice.
Oh, my defense doll.
Medicine.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, we recovered!
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh, geez, oh geez, oh geez, oh geez, oh geez, oh geez, oh
geez.
I don't know, forget...
Oh my god.
I thought it was gonna be like a joke of a thing, you know
what I mean?
Like a joke.
That's why I tried all the items first.
Stamina.
My attack went up!
I should have done that first.
Holy cow.
Oh, no, my defense, though.
I think I need to do...
I need to heal.
He's gonna kill me.
Okay.
But my attack went up.
Oh!
Oh my god!
He's not... Oh gosh!
Oh no!
Ah!
It's so over.
It's so over!
My defense!
11 damage We did it Holy cow Oh my god I think it would have
been over for us in the next turn Oh my god I think it would
have been over for us in the next one Holy cow Oh
We were so I
went through that whole arc just to miss the very slow
falling.
Oh my god!
Sorry guys, I fumbled that one.
I fumbled that one for real.
Oh my god!
Really keeps it on your toes, huh?
Oh my god, I'm sick of this one, I think.
Why'd you just stare at it?
I wasn't staring, I was clicking.
I was!
It just didn't look like I was, but I was.
It didn't look like it.
But I was.
I didn't...
I was like, no way there would be a second.
I think those reflexes are dead.
I mean, I am dead, so...
Oh.
Nope.
Yes.
Oh.
Wait.
I don't
know how from here.
I don't know how.
I
don't like these.
I'm so bad at them.
I've never learned the trick on how to do them.
I'm just random clicking for real though.
Oh, okay, it's this one.
Oh, it's one of these types of puzzles.
Kind of.
Oh, shoot.
Oh.
Wait, why does that one uncheck?
What the hell?
You are not...
Wait, why are some of these unchecking?
What?
Why did you uncheck?
Why?
I think I had it.
No!
Uh...
Is this the one that zooms by?
Wait, what is this?
What is going on in this?
Meow.
Whala de bemco.
Keep scrolling.
I did.
Alright, let's...
80?
Get the 80?
No!
We're not having such good luck here, guys.
Okay, we're at zero.
80!
30?
50?
Yes!
Okay.
60!
Oh!
None!
Wait, did that divide by two?
Oh, maybe it divided by zero?
Oh, no, you can't divide by zero.
There's going to be some sort of weird paradox thing.
I don't know.
Oh, my gosh, we're so close.
Please.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
No!
Okay.
Oh, I think we made it!
Ah!
We made it!
We made it, we made it, we made it.
Ah!
Which one is this one?
No!
It's
time!
Okay, I got it, I got it.
It's like right here, isn't it?
It's like right down here?
It is this one, right?
Oh.
Oh, oh.
Wait a second.
It's not.
Oh!
Oh, I see it.
Dang.
I was so certain.
I was so ready.
Love.
Banana peel slipping ass sound effect.
I know!
What is the name of the person you like?
Can't tell you guys that!
Hi, boo.
Wait, do I push it into a corner or...
There we go.
It runs away from me because it likes me and it's nervous.
Wait, what is this?
No way.
Is this...
It's like a game!
I never played that.
Wait, I read a bit.
carefully.
I read it carefully.
Uh.
Oh my god.
Sleek again.
I never played this though.
At least it gives you a lot of time, it seems.
I read it carefully.
Hooy!
Oh!
Nice, nice, nice.
Okay, where are we at?
Completely understood.
Unconfirmed.
Where's I read a bit?
I read it carefully like here-ish.
Oh no, I can't get to the unconfirmed.
Oh no, I messed up.
Oh no, I can't get to the I read a bit either.
Oh no, I think I messed up.
Oh no, oh, oh, nice, nice, nice.
I read it carefully.
I read a bit.
Oh, shoot.
I meant it.
Okay.
Maybe I could push it.
Yeah.
They're all so similar.
It's really hard to...
Come on, come on.
No, please.
Okay, unconfirmed.
Over here.
Push them.
Yes!
I kind of agree.
We're close.
I think...
I need to do, I read a bit over here.
Yes, so...
Okay.
Kind of agree.
We're so close.
I wish I could just drop it my own.
You know what I mean?
Like, rather than it.
Okay, read it carefully.
No.
It's so far.
Read it carefully.
Oh, I should have dropped it.
Okay, please, please.
Unconfirmed.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Maybe I can knock this one over.
Yes!
What is read carefully?
Oh my gosh, I...
I'll read a bit, okay.
Ah!
Oh!
Um...
Read a bit.
Read a bit Read a bit Read a bit Read a bit
No you're supposed to Oh no Oh no
Guys I think it's over
It's so over
I've never played sick again
all right what you know what maybe doki doki exciting game
is overrated
one more round oh oh i caught that one okay you should try
agreeing instead of disagreeing i don't think i've ever
thought of that oh which one is no wait which which one is
it what is it what is it what is it Where is it?
Where is it?
Who is it?
How is it?
Where is it coming from?
Who is it?
Where is it?
Hello?
Is it one of those that's hidden in the sky?
Oh, okay, it's this one.
Traumatized!
I'm having an actual trauma response!
Select all the tiles that contain cream, soda, up yummy okay
these are really small boxes so i'm gonna check anything
that even has a sliver of soda in it everything is i i know
this game by now i know your tricks and your plays and i
know that you'll want every even if there's a pixel i can't
tell with this one if there's a pixel or not.
Look at this!
This looks like...
Like me.
Like, does that count?
Is that the reflection?
Glass of ectoplasm.
Yes, yes, yes!
What's this one?
Oh, it's this one.
Oh, shoot.
I don't like this one.
Are you kidding me right now?
I clicked it.
You guys saw I clicked that one.
Oh my god, I clicked that one too!
Game?
Game is sabotaging me?
Game is sabotaging me!
No!
Please, game!
I'm hitting agree, I promise!
I'm pressing the button, please register my input!
Ah!
Could you double tap?
Whatever, it doesn't matter.
You agreed that the devs are human, too.
Two-factor authentic...
Uh, oh.
We had that.
Love your cursor.
Thank you.
Hackermade.
fastest thingies in the west oh yeah baby all right fraud oh
oh why did i do that sorry
this one it's overused game i've seen this one enough times
now it's not cute anymore
more imagine after all that you accidentally hit this
hookery where's your motivation i watched it i watched them
all like disappear within them within each other actually i
didn't see where this one went okay
matroshka how did that vocaloid song go
oh no no no wait is it wait No.
Oh, okay, it's this one.
Okay, it's this one.
Agreed.
Oh.
You'll get smaller, right?
Get smaller!
Oh, it's going at a snail's pace.
Wait.
Oh, my God.
Not a stupid one like that.
Okay, hold on.
Oh, it's this again.
Oh my god.
I'm just gonna hover over one area.
There we go.
And on a win!
What is this one?
I like seeing all the new ones too.
Oh.
It's turning?
So close.
Yes, pillow.
Woo!
Is that a yes, no pillow?
It absolutely is.
Select all the body parts you like!
You are not confirmed you are confirmed not to be a robot.
Very human-like.
Be honest, Minto.
I am.
I am honest.
Oh, no.
Where are you coming?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh.
What is that?
I wish, um...
I wish on the menu that there was...
That there was a...
Like, you can choose which mini-game.
Because I would go until I can get the zooming shot.
Oh.
Oh no!
Oh okay.
Oh this is tricky.
You can pick a game?
Oh!
There's a casual mode.
After maybe once I lose I'll try it and go until I...
We're so close.
Here it is.
The winner.
The winner!
Yippee!
Oh, it's this one again.
I think it's in the same spot that it was before.
No!
Oh, no, no, no.
No, no, no.
Oh, shoot.
Oh.
Ow!
That one is hard.
That one is difficult.
All right, casual mode.
Wait.
Is that...
Retry penalty.
Wait, return the title.
Ah, I see.
No, Brandon, you're totally fine.
Thank you for the super chat.
I hope you're feeling good.
Snow was beautiful.
Feeling better now, though.
I hope you're well.
You too.
Take it easy.
Wait.
So...
Ah, cool.
No, I thought...
What I mentioned is I wish there was an option to pick
whichever...
Like the mini-game that you want to do, you know what I
mean?
Hmm...
But that's okay.
I am clicking it.
I am clicking agree.
Juke?
20.
22.
71 thank you guys what if this is the one we don't even need
to retry you know what i mean wouldn't that be so hilarious
where we just get a ton of easy
we got this
I mean,
look.
I wasn't saying that this one was going to be easy.
Come on.
It's literally hitting everything by it.
Please.
Can I hit it now?
Oh, okay.
I can.
Nice flag you threw up there.
What is this?
What
is this?
Streamer lock!
More blue.
I'd say that's pretty close.
What?
How close do they need to be?
No, it's not more red.
Definitely not more red.
We had it.
Within five minutes.
percent oh nice
what is this oh but
this is like those games those are those like pew pew pew
pew pew pew pew pew yeah those gamers yeah yeah yeah
Oh, nice.
It's taking mega damage.
Pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew,
pew, pew, pew, I need to stop paying attention.
Peel,
peel, peel, peel, peel, peel, peel, peel, peel, peel, peel,
peel, peel, peel, okay, okay, we're good.
Uh-oh, wait, uh-oh, uh-oh, uh-oh, uh-oh, uh-oh, uh, uh, uh,
there we go, okay.
Oh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, this is how these games are in the
ads, too.
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh.
Peel, peel, peel, peel, peel, peel, peel, peel, peel, peel,
peel, why can't I send a ton at once?
Oh, oh, guys, it's so over.
It's so over for us.
Oh my god.
Oh, it's differing each time now, too.
Hmm.
The flood gate has opened.
At least it doesn't multiply or anything.
Wait, how?
How do they want me to do this?
I was trying to open up that one but oh my god please this
is unfair how am I supposed to get the one if all of my
things are avoiding it this is a tougher one it seems pretty
tough yeah because we're so slow our little attack oh my
gosh oh there's the floodgates we're so we're so it's over
first Oh my gosh, on the other side too.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Ouch, ouch.
Oh, it's over.
This one's hard.
I don't like this one.
Shuffle retry.
Oh, I see it.
Oh my god.
We can do this one.
Re-try, retry, retry.
Ouch.
We can do this one.
We try it.
We try.
We can do this one.
We can do this.
Shot.
What am I doing?
Oh, she's stuck.
No.
I like trying.
I like trying all the ways, though, to like, all the
different games are pretty fun.
shuffle retry.
Agreed.
The agreement program is infected with a virus.
It's kind of dangerous, so please fix the program.
Be careful that the agree button does not come into contact
with the surrounding agreement virus.
Am I supposed to explode these?
Oh!
Wait, what?
Actually, I'm confused.
Hold on.
Am I supposed to explode these or...
Oh,
like that!
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
I was trapped!
There is nothing I could have done!
There's nothing I could have done!
This one seems doable.
I just have to be really fast in the beginning.
Before they start coming in.
Oh, oh.
Oh, shoot.
Okay, maybe it's okay.
We're about to do it.
The final boss.
No way the final boss is this!
My attack.
My's turn.
12 damage.
Can I do... What was the... What made my defense go up?
My naughty book made me hard.
Yes, my body.
It's like hardened.
You know?
And Pokemon.
I'm gonna throw my sword.
Ultimate sword!
Yeah!
Oh gosh!
Okay, hold on.
16 HP!
I'm gonna do...
Medicine!
Oh, that's my MP.
I forgot.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, he's sleeping!
Final Fantagree.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna magic.
I'm gonna heal.
Okay, five damage.
Okay, it's not bad.
And...
Oh!
Space.
Oh.
Oh my god.
This is also a rage game.
Oh my god, no.
I think this is also a rage game.
No way.
What's this S for?
Shortcut to the goal!
Oh, shut up.
It
took me 50 minutes.
No.
It took us 50 minutes.
The music is so cute.
Hey, actually, is it even possible to make it through the
jump, that part with the...
I want to actually play it, you know what I mean?
Like, I want to play this one.
Oh, it is!
Oh my gosh.
It's like one of those crazy, like, Mario levels that people
make.
No cannibalism either.
Curse is broken for now.
Just don't jump too high.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Yippee!
Yeah, Mario levels.
Nice.
Maybe one day I'll actually attempt it.
But for now, die.
Hot dog indeed.
I'm gonna call it here.
Thank you so much, Dry Princess.
Thank you.
I'm gonna call it here.
We shall raid a dokey bird for her second year anniversary.
No cannibalism, but we are hungry.
Sorry it's a bit of a shorter stream today, but I had fun.
I hope you guys did too.
Mission failed!
Woo!
We beat the game!
Welcome back.
Thank you.
Death to Clarity.
Thank you for the peek.
Thank you so much.
Fish and Mail.
Yeah.
Fake me.
Thank you.
Doki Doki, action ray.
This is so goofy.
I didn't even rage once.
I still wish I could have gotten the Zoomy one, though.
I wish I could have gotten it.
One day I will have my revenge.
day.
I was hoping I would get that one in the replay thing.
I should have just kept doing it until I, like, kept
shuffling until I got it.
That's okay.
I think I... Wait.
Wait, am I on casual?
Oh, hold on.
Wait, oh, wait, hold on.
Let me double check.
Okay, shuffle retry.
Here we go.
I think I'm addicted Oh it's this one Wait hold on Shuffle,
shuffle Shuffle Shuffle retry No No
Wait where is it?
Where's the disagree?
We'll hit it on purpose Disagree I know you're in here Wait,
there is one in here, right?
There it is, okay Wait, I could have just passed it at that
point Oh wait, this one's due?
What do you want to ask about?
Why does my tummy rumble?
I'm not really sure.
Then choose a question from these.
Can you freely draw on the oboe rice with ketchup?
Oh.
Anything else?
No.
Yes.
No, no, no, yes, yes, agree.
There was an encyclopedia in the settings.
Which one is it called?
How to you erase you and the consent?
Oh, wait.
I read it wrong.
How to erase?
Oh, wait.
have a non-check on it because i've never done it before
crossing consent maybe it's this one okay we got this we got
this i feel so vindicated right now thank you so much
everybody i'll see you when i see you next bye bye bye bye
thank you Bye bye, bye bye!
Bye bye!
Okay, thank you so much for that, guys so far!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you!